617 830 4750 we have someone who's been
holding for a while here they must have
a really really good question for me
because they've been holding for a
little while name and where you're
calling from caller yes hello David arm
this is rob from there and I called last
week what's up what's up what's going on
yes I'll just called ass because you
have a task list to our Donald Trump
song press coffee today I did yes so
what did you think about it I thought
that he was feeling around in the dark I
thought that he exposed that he barely
has any idea what it is he's even doing
he seemed to have very little sense of
just what the hell is going on right I
mean to borrow a phrase from him your
hairy lawyer up there explaining how
they fix the conflicts of interest and
when the camera would show Trump on the
side he seemed sort of a combination
between confused and bored he had to
look on his face that a dog has when it
hears its owner's voice coming out of an
answering machine sort of like vague
recognition of what's being discussed
but not really understanding exactly
what's happening it was very weird and
then when he got into the shouting match
with the CNN reporter saying your fake
news I mean everything about it was
pathetic and embarrassing I agree one
hundred percent you know we do know he
spent the entire press confe just
talking the questions and um you know he
still refuses to release his tax returns
he says that didn't care about Hillary
white people that care if the arm
journalist is what he was fan ya know it
was insane it was longer it was a gong
show it was indistinguishable from a
Saturday Night Live parody of what a
trump press conference we are out of
time thank you so much for the call
really appreciate it always great to
hear from people from all over the
country and sometimes the world we will
take a break david pakman.com slash
donate is the one place to donate to the
indiegogo campaign and of course sign up
for membership david pakman.com slash
membership